und wir sprechen über dieses foto ein
recht freizügiges bei instagram hat
verona das gepostet dabei zeigt sie sich
oben ohne unter der dusche auf mallorca
die fans fanden das ganz gut doch sie
hat kürzlich das foto gelöscht und es
durch ein züchtiges nämlich dieses hier
ersetzt bewohner pooth ja warum denn die
löschung dieses oben ohne fotos hallo
naja ohne die hände man ja davor
sonst hätte ich ja gleich über den leben
zu sagen können es war einfach ein spaß
mit einer freundin und abends sind uns
sicher dass können wir sind raus
schicken und dann sehr spät als ich nach
hause kam habe normales handy geschaut
und so viele tolle kommen die wendigen
kriegt und dazu ein bisschen leid getan
weil ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ihr
resonanz auch im netz so positives das
netz kann ja auch manchmal anders da war
ich ganz fit und habe aber gedacht das
ist eine nummer zu hat die bild hat ja
geschrieben verboten
sexy und das fand ich sehr lustig heute
mit pooth im namen ja also ich hab es
dann raus genommen dann dachte ich mir
okay machst du einfach das ursprüngliche
bild wie es auch geplant war ein
wir haben jetzt ist es halt doch überall
netz vergisst nie sie sind doch
eigentlich social media profi da ist man
dann aber auch trotzdem obwohl man profi
ist dann doch spontan und postet mal so
ein foto wie uns allen das
wahrscheinlich schon mal passiert ist
also ist möglichen emotions menschen das
merkt man ja meine ganzen auch zu reden
und wenn man nicht ein bisschen länger
aus den medien kennen wenn mir das
andere bild haben wir ja auch gut
gefallen das war ja nicht so dass das
aus versehen war und ich stehe auch dazu
es war einfach eine nummer zu hart und
ich hab dann irgendwie gedacht jetzt
nimmst du es heute wieder raus weil von
mir gibt es ja viele bikini fotos und
ich freue mich natürlich über die tollen
kommentare und das andere bild habe ich
ja auch bewusst aufgenommen